quien me hizo conocer los efectos de la guerra en la psique.
Cuando mi abuelo fue Infante de la Marina en la Guerra de Corea,
una bala le perforó el cuello, dejándolo sin poder gritar.
Vio cómo un médico del ejército siguió de largo,
dándolo por desahuciado,
y dejándolo ahí para morir.
Años después, cuando sus heridas físicas habían sanado
y había regresado a casa,
rara vez hablaba durante el día de sus experiencias.
Pero, durante la noche, lo oía gritar obscenidades
al otro lado del pasillo.
Al entrar a su cuarto de día, siempre anunciaba mi llegada
para no sobresaltarlo o agitarlo.
Vivió el resto de sus días
aislado y reservado,
nunca encontrando la manera de poderse expresar,
y yo, en ese entonces, no tenía las herramientas para ayudarlo.
No supe el nombre de la condición de mi abuelo
hasta alcanzar mis veinte años.
Al querer graduarme en Arteterapia,
naturalmente me incliné por el estudio del trauma.
Y, al aprender en clase sobre el trastorno por estrés postraumático,
o TEPT,
mi misión de ayudar a militares que han sufrido como mi abuelo
comenzó a tomar forma.
Le hemos dado diversos nombres al estrés postraumático
desde el inicio de las guerras:
añoranza,
corazón de soldado,
aturdimiento,
mirada de los mil metros, entre otros.
Y mientras estudiaba, una nueva guerra se intensificaba,
y, gracias a los modernos chalecos antibalas y vehículos militares,
los soldados ahora sobrevivían a explosiones.
Pero, las heridas invisibles alcanzaban nuevos niveles,
y esto llevó a que médicos e investigadores militares
trataran de entender realmente los efectos de una lesión cerebral traumática o TBI,
y del trastorno por estrés postraumático en el cerebro.
Gracias a los avances en tecnología y a las neuroimágenes,
ahora sabemos que ocurre un bloqueo en el área de Broca;
esto es, el área del lenguaje del cerebro, cuando un individuo sufre un trauma.
Este cambio fisiológico,
o "terror sin habla", como también se le conoce,
unido al estigma de cordura,
el temor a ser juzgados
o incomprendidos,
tal vez hasta apartados de sus tareas actuales,
conduce a las batallas invisibles de nuestros militares, hombres y mujeres.
Generaciones de veteranos
han preferido no hablar de sus experiencias,
y sufren en solitario.
Tuve un gran reto al tener mi primer trabajo
como arteterapeuta en el mayor centro médico militar del país,
Walter Reed.
Tras trabajar un par de años en la unidad de pacientes internados,
me transfirieron al Centro Intrépido Nacional de Excelencia, NICoE,
que lidera el cuidado de TBI para militares en activo.
Yo creía en la arteterapia,
pero tenía que convencer a los militares,
grandes, rudos, fuertes, masculinos,
y a algunas mujeres también,
de que ofrecieran hacer arte como tratamiento psicoterapéutico.
Los resultados han sido espectaculares.
Nuestros militares, hombres y mujeres
están creando obras de arte vívidas y simbólicas,
y cada obra cuenta una historia.
Hemos observado que el proceso del arteterapia esquiva
el problema habla-lenguaje en el cerebro.
Hacer arte accede a las áreas sensoriales del cerebro que codifican el trauma.
Los militares pueden aprovechar el arte para trabajar sus experiencias
de una manera no amenazante.
Pueden posteriormente nombrar o describir sus obras,
reintegrando los hemisferios izquierdo y derecho del cerebro.
Hemos observado que esto funciona con cualquier tipo de arte --
dibujo, pintura, collage --
pero lo que parece tener el mayor impacto
es hacer máscaras.
Al fin y al cabo, estas heridas invisibles no sólo tienen un nombre,
tienen también una cara.
Y cuando los militares crean estas máscaras,
literalmente tocan y lidian con el trauma.
Y es impresionante cómo eso les permite
fracturar el trauma y comenzar a sanar.
Recuerdan la CSB?
Eso fue una experiencia real para uno de mis pacientes,
y cuando creó su máscara,
pudo superar esa imagen que lo atormentaba.
Al principio, fue un proceso abrumador para el paciente,
pero, poco a poco, comenzó a identificar la CSB como máscara
y no como su herida interna,
y cada vez que terminábamos una sesión,
me entregaba la máscara y me decía, "Melissa, cuídalo".
Después de un tiempo, metimos a la CSB en una caja, para contenerla y dominarla,
y cuando el paciente dejó el NICoE,
decidió dejar la CSB.
Un año después, había visto a la CSB sólo dos veces,
y, en ambas ocasiones la CSB sonreía
y el paciente no sintió angustia.
Ahora, cada vez que es atormentado por algún recuerdo traumático,
sigue pintando.
Y cada vez que pinta estas imágenes perturbadoras,
las ve con menos frecuencia o deja de verlas por completo.
Los filósofos nos han dicho desde hace miles de años
que el poder de crear
está íntimamente relacionado con el poder de destrucción.
Ahora la ciencia nos muestra que el área del cerebro
que registra una lesión traumática
puede ser la misma parte del cerebro donde ocurre la sanación.
Y, el arteterapia nos enseña cómo hacer esa conexión.
Le pedimos a uno de nuestros pacientes
que describiera cómo el hacer máscaras ha impactado en su tratamiento,
y esto fue lo que dijo.
(Video) Paciente: Simplemente te pierdes en la máscara.
Te pierdes en el dibujo,
y me desbloqueó,
y por eso pude hacerlo.
Y, cuando la vi después de dos días, dije
"Dios mío, ésta es la pintura, ésta es la llave, éste es el acertijo,"
y, a partir de ahí, mi tratamiento se disparó
es decir, se desahogó,
porque me decían, Kurt, explica esto, explica esto.
Y, por primera vez en 23 años,
pude realmente hablar abiertamente con cualquiera.
Podría hablarles de ello ahora si quisiera,
porque lo liberé.
Es impresionante.
Y me permitió colocar 23 años de TEPT
y de TBI en un solo lugar.
Eso nunca me había pasado.
Lo siento.
Melissa Walker: En los últimos 5 años
se han hecho más de mil máscaras.
Es increíble, no?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Me hubiera encantado compartir este proceso con mi abuelo,
pero sé que estaría emocionado
de que estamos encontrando maneras
para ayudar a sanar a los militares de hoy y mañana,
y dándoles herramientas internas
que pueden utilizar
para sanarse a sí mismos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)